musulmans ils ont réformiste
s'appuie sur certaines traditions de
l'islam sur certains mouvements de
l'islam au cours de l'histoire pour dire
oui on peut on va y arriver on va
vraiment créer un islam de livres pour
le moment impression qu on est dans
quelque chose de très marginale
[Musique]
les organisations musulmanes doivent
naviguer finalement entre trois poules
d'une part ils sont musulmans donc
attaché quand même en principe au coran
à la parole du prophète deuxièmement
leurs bases nourris et largement par la
propagande des frères musulmans et les
salafistes serra et troisièmement la
pression de la république et ils
divergent trop par rapport aux valeurs
de la république
ils vont faire monter l'extrême droite
la façon dont évolue disant l'opinion à
l'égard de l'islam n'est pas fait pour
les rassurer cette formation disons des
imams est de fournir aux zimmer une
espèce de doctrine play en clé en main
qui soit un compromis
raisonnable entre eux les valeurs de la
république les textes du coran et les
points de vue de leurs bas c'est
tellement difficile d'abord je ne savais
pas étonnant qu'ils soient pas d'accord
entre eux entre les frères musulmans qui
ont craint tout une une habitude de la
négociation en fin de 2 d'essayer de se
présenter sous le mais l'islam sous le
meilleur jour pour progresser disons
dans la dent dans la république en plus
les rivalités entre l'algérie le maroc
et c'est donc il ya tout pour arriver à
la division auxquelles on a assisté
il n'y a pas d'impossibilité
radical et les musulmans ils ont
réformiste
s'appuie sur certaines traditions de
l'islam sur certains mouvements de
l'islam au cours de l'histoire pour dire
oui on peut on va y arriver on va
vraiment créer un islam de livres pour
le moment l'impression tourner dans
quelque chose de très marginal et que
ceux qui se lancent dans cette aventure
s'ils sont radicaux sont taxés
d'apostats ou alors quand un couple
roues par exemple sont des grands
navigateurs qui à la fois appartiennent
aux frères musulmans mais disent ils en
sont plus vraiment y assureront une
concurrence entre tous d'une série de
mouvements depuis des musulmans qui
réellement ont été jours pourrait dire
converti par l'occident finances ont
converti aux valeurs de l'occident la
liberté de conscience sont convertir
l'idée d'égalité des hommes des femmes
et puis à ce qui est
dit l'on reprenne une stratégie je
dirais et roxy va on va s'implanter dans
les syndicats dans les conseils
municipaux dans les dents les
associations caritatives puis à ceux qui
continuent finalement être dans un islam
je dirais traditionnels comme les
l'islam soufi thomistes il peut
intéresser à la politique
ce qui fait obstacle enfin la simulation
disons des individus c'est le fait
l'islam donc est une religion avec donc
les cinq pays el-islah le jeûne la
prière la profession de foi le
pèlerinage mélissa mais en même temps un
ordre social et politique hostile à la
liberté de conscience allait militer
entre les hommes et les femmes pour que
les musulmans disent on s'assimile il
faut au fort qu'ils acceptent une
séparation de l'aspect vraiment
religieux qu'ils toute sa place et qui
fut couvert à la liberté de conscience
et puis l'aspect construction d'une
contre société d'un ordre social et
politique est inacceptable pour les
france il faut aussi que l'islam arrive
de l'intérieur afin de cette affaire
c'est cette distance que l'état commence
à faire en même temps une certaine
pression sur cet aspect disons sociales
et politiques incompatibles avec les
valeurs françaises a un rôle à jouer
sous les dents
l'évolution de l'islam lui-même enfin
c'est ce qui s'est passé si vous voulez
avec le judaïsme au moment de la
révolution française
[Musique]